bonjour est ce que vous m'entendez bilan
vous pouvez nous le signaler sur le chat
alors apparemment
tous nos enfants ah oui merci farrar
bonjour alors je suis sandrine charles
je m'occupe de la communication de la
chambre de métiers d'artisanat de france
je vous souhaite la bienvenue à ce
webinaire qui sera consacrée à la
thématique de gagner en visibilité avec
le label réparateur ce webinaire est
organisé par la chambre de métiers
d'artisanat bits de france essonne dans
le cadre de la semaine nationale du
développement durable qui a vu en ce
moment du 20 au 26 septembre
alors réparateur c'est un site qui vise
à mettre en lumière tous les artisans de
la fabrication dont je pense vous faites
partie et à mieux connaître les enjeux
et les bénéfices de la démarche
citoyenne éco responsable auprès du
grand public au cours de cette table en
rond nous allons tenter autant que
possible de vous livrer toutes les clés
qu'offre cet annuaire en ligne pour cela
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir trois
artisans
essonniens qui ont bien voulu témoigner
de leur
leurs pratiques
préparateur donc il s'agit de florence
lebouc dirigeants de pc up une
entreprise de dépannage et de réparation
informatique créée en 2006 et qui est
située à morcenx orange bonjour fabre
bonjour bonjour adrien garcia vous êtes
artisan d'art
coutelier vous avez créé en 2018 reflet
de l'âme et votre entreprise de
coutellerie y est installé
beaune en effet
merci d'être là adrien
bonjour lui vint boubacar j'ai bien
commencé vous êtes dirigeant de haut
clés du jardin une entreprise de
réparation et d'entretien d'outils
dédiés au jardinage que vous avez créée
en 2009 à brétigny vous dirais que plus
tard dans l'homme au cours du binaire
puisqu'il ya une autre particularité
autour de votre votre activité qui est
lié à l'insertion des jeunes eux
mathieu des gains vilcocq rim a dit yeux
vous êtes chargé de développement
durable au service développement
économique de la chambre de métiers
d'artisanat d'île de france
notre siège donc et votre thématique de
référence et la transition écologique
des entreprises artisanales le
développement durable dans tous les
services et produits qui tourne autour
pour la chambre de métiers et puis pour
finir car le budget carole buge tu as je
vais plutôt frileux même battu les
charges de développement économique au
sein de la cemac ile de france essonne
et tuée particulièrement référent du
développement durable donc voilà notre
webinaire va commencer mais avant tout
je voulais vous dire que si vous avez
des questions à poser n'hésitez surtout
pas à les poser sur le chat qui à votre
disposition donc vous pouvez tout est
question que qui vous passe par la tête
nous allons les relevés et nous les
traiterons dans la dernière partie du
webinaire au moment des questions
réponses
mathieu je te donne la parole et je vous
retrouve tout à l'heure pour les
questions
et les échanges sur ses béquilles
merci beaucoup
en effet des enjeux sont autour de la
réparation est pourquoi les chambres des
métiers d'artisanat
ont développé cette cet annuaire de la
réparation et de la belle réparé acteurs
bien sûr promouvoir les entreprises
artisanales de la réparation on va
pouvoir qui va voir qu'il ya différents
enjeux importants qui sont liées à cette
à cette action de deux enjeux principaux
qui sont les enjeux environnementaux
bien sûr
avec la l'épuisement des ressources
naturelles et la réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre pardon et les
déchets et la production de déchets donc
les ressources naturelles la matière
première qui peut aussi avoir des enjeux
forts sur l'approvisionnement
contexte actuel et surtout le réduction
des émissions de gaz a fait cadeau à
effet de serre qui seront en vidéo aux
changements climatiques parce qu'on va
avoir une action sur la fabrication le
transport la distribution l'utilisation
et la fin de vie des produits
un autre enjeu force et les enjeux
économiques rallonger la durée de vie
des produits ça ça nous permet aux
consommateurs des liens financiers
ce consommateur aujourd'hui il a deux
enjeux forts auprès de la réparation et
deux moyens d'accéder à la réparation
c'est lorsqu'un appareil est sous
garantie qu'il peut voir avec le
fabricant ou un réparateur agréé le fait
de réparer sont produites ou sinon dans
un cadre hors garantie
aller voir un professionnel artisan près
de chez lui pour
réparer son produit alors attention sur
les enjeux financiers la réparation
l'étude ademe a montré que 30 % de la
valeur du produit neuf était le prix
psychologique pour la réparer réparer
son produit on a surtout le aussi des
enjeux de
de comportements des acteurs qui est des
consommateurs qui est en train de
changer avec l'économie circulaire qui
est en train de se développer à la fois
dans les dents les enjeux de stratégie
d'entreprise
l'économie circulaire on sort du schéma
produits rachetés consommer jeter à
produire acheter consommer réparer ça
m'amène à une question mathieu que j'ai
vraiment waziers habiba alors on a dit
tout à l'heure vous l'aviez une
particularité
le modèle économique de votre entreprise
vous êtes engagé dans une stratégie
d'économie circulaire au près depuis la
création de votre entreprise et comment
comment ça se traduit au quotidien dans
l'exercice de votre activité
alors merci donc je vois tous les
participants voilà le sont au coeur du
jardin dans la réparation de machines de
jardinage et nous avons donc trois axes
très important le premier sert par l
ancien n'a reçu suivre le nouveau est
aussi utilisé cette activité pour servir
de support d'insertion personnes qui
sont éloignés de l'emploi en difficulté
dans un parcours format tiff
est aujourd'hui notre société non
seulement à partir la fédération des
entreprises d'insertion mais aussi à la
sédiments qui est un syndicat des
professionnelles la discussion des
machines jardin pour faire le point au
niveau de l'emploi est à ce niveau donc
comme l'a dit
tout à l'heure le prédécesseur que
l''indice des repas réhabilité est
largement respectée et il ya des
évolutions ont le sens au niveau par
l'ombre des grands distributeurs
hier la
codi bip
[Rires]
merci merci débat
en effet des enjeux forts sont son cours
de dévolution sur ces gens de la
réparation avec des contraintes
réglementaires et un contexte
réglementaire qui va évoluer
façon positive pour les acteurs de la
réparation avec la la loi à chacun la
loi relative à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et à l'écu et l'économie
circulaire
ce cette loi qui est en train d'être
déployé à la lier à la sortie de décret
à différents axes dont des axes qui sont
dédiés à la réparation un désaxé
importance et l'extension de garantie
globalement pour faire simple et rentes
ne pas rentrer dans des décrets
réglementaires
extension de garantie donc 4 de
réparation et et ongles enjeu très fort
d'autres axes correspondant à la loi
anti gaspillage économie circulaire ou à
jacques il ya à agir contre
l'obsolescence programmée et lundi se
devait de barra de réparabilité
pour avoir un effet plus explicative les
appareils de certaines familles alors
actuellement ce sera sur les téléviseurs
smart phones tondeuse et ordinateurs
vont avoir un indice comme pour les
consommations énergétiques actuellement
lorsque vous achetez un lave linge par
exemple des lettres à a+ plus il y aura
la même chose sur l' indice de
réparabilité sur le la possibilité de
réparer un appareil
des coûts florence où vous quelques
apparitions informatique c'est que vous
êtes concerné es ce que vous avez
observé
des cas
de programmation
d'obsolescence qui sont programmés des
observations qui sont programmés sur les
pc ou réparés oui dès le début de
l'ouverture de notre activité on l'a
constaté directement parce que des
ordinateurs qui avait dépassé la
garantie d'un mois ou deux mois tombé en
panne alors que mater systématiquement
alors on peut dire c'est pas de chance
sur un modèle qui finalement sur le
modèle de la même marque on a vu arriver
bain beaucoup de gens qui venaient avec
ce problème là donc nous on ne répare
effectivement hors garantie donc un coût
un peu élevé pour le pour le client
certaines marques le malheureusement
nous le disent aussi faire de la
l'obsolescence programmée on le voit
quand on doit préparer un ordinateur ou
c'est bien marqué changer votre disque
dur quand on analyse le disque dur il va
bien mais on est obligé de changer la
pièce donc oui ça existe certaines
grandes marques aussi d'imprimantes le
feu vous ne pouvez pas aujourd'hui
mettre une cartouche d'encre qui n'est
pas de la marque sinon elle tombe en
panne donc ça ça arrive
alors heureusement ça commence à évoluer
je pense que les marques grâce aussi aux
associations de consommateurs qui
mettent la pression sur
ses marques et font évoluer aussi leurs
pratiques et des marques d'imprimantes
par exemple aujourd'hui qui sont dans
des gammes qu'on appelle échos tank qui
permet justement d'avoir un coût moindre
puisque ce ne sont plus des cartouches
d'encre que nous avons mais des
bouteilles d'encre donc recharger pour
recharger extérieur qu en fait chaque
couleur à sa bouteille et vous
remplissez selon l'utilisation que vous
en faites donc il ya plus de gaspillage
des break avant les cartouches elle
faisait cette limite aujourd'hui une
bouteille ses 170 mille litres de
cartouches de noir à 15 euros ce qui est
quand même beaucoup plus économique
voilà alors le pour le ce changement de
pratique de la part des constructeurs
quelle incidence el had sur le marché
parce que du coup elle va avoir une
incidence il me sens direct sur votre
activité de réparation alors vous avez
vous calez parade pour rassasier pour
swiss finalement des machines qui sont
plus durables
alors même ça va atteindre le marché
alors elles sont plus durables il ya l
on trouve quand même des pièces qu'on
peut réparer la coque même si
effectivement elles sont plus durables
on n'a plus cette tendance à les jeter
puisqu'avant effectivement il était
possible de finalement de mettre à la
poubelle aujourd'hui nous aujourd'hui on
trouve les pièces on va pouvoir réparer
un écran aujourd'hui qui tourne en panne
il suffit de le malade est notée et de
tribunaux talent alors moi j'utilise
aussi beaucoup l'occasion c'est à dire
récupérer sur une machine un écran une
dalle et l'art l'art on va dire l'art
est implanté dans sur un autre
ordinateur ça évite aussi d'acheter des
pièces
les modèles sont voilà ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les modèles sont
impressionnants d'art maintenant ça
aussi c'est important la standardisation
des pièces
l'usb aujourd'hui voilà par exemple les
dalles c'est la même connectique les
disques durs c'est la même connectique
la même taille donc voilà on trouve des
pièces qui sont standard qui me
permettent de réparer vue mais nous
sommes là le marché plutôt au contraire
recontré à se bouchent exactement
auxerre aujourd'hui on a vraiment besoin
de réparateur d'ordinateurs
[Musique]
à mais complètement ok merci
non mais ça doit bien nous devons dire
sur des bonnes pratiques
qu'on peut qu'on peut avoir cité et donc
justement la loi va imposer ce système
avec
l'application proposée en tout cas aux
clients des pièces issues d'économie
circulaire c'est à dire des pièces
reprises sur des appareils défectueux ou
permettre la réparation dans un cadre
légal
un des points importants aussi qui va
favoriser la réparation qui va entraîner
fortement la réparation d'appareils de
développer l'activité c'est la mise à
disponibilité des pièces détachées de la
part des constructeurs est également le
fond de la réparation préfon de la
réparation c'est un enjeu très très fort
sur
sur le activités de réparateurs seul
objectif c'est de créer un fond il ya
une taxe qui s'appelle
responsabilité élargie du producteur
quitter aujourd'hui très ouvert très
focalisés sur le recyclage des appareils
c'est la petite taxe que les
consommateurs payent lors de l'achat
d'un appareil iphone est
exactement est aujourd'hui une partie de
ce fonds va être dédiée à la réparation
et ça va permettre de prendre
à des entreprises labellisées
[Musique]
d'avoir une partie de la facture qui est
prise en charge
donc actuellement le label il est dédié
sur la compétence et le savoir faire des
artisans et sur le fait que l'artisan
s'engage à promouvoir la réparation les
grandes lignes de la création sont
sortis et le label le visera ces
entreprises là
le second point c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
le fond de la pression va uniquement se
focaliser sur certaines
réparations il ya les appareils
électroniques dans un second temps les
choses vont se développer pour un mètre
de toucher l'ensemble des activités de
la réparation
donc ce contexte plutôt
engageant pour la réparation il a été
aussi permis par le travail de la
chambre des métiers d'artisanat avec la
création d'un annuel et la création du
label créé par acteurs pour faire un
explication sur cette labellisation est
sûre cet annuaire cette demande faite
par l'état un diadème et laisser chambre
des métiers d'artisanat
historiquement elle est liée à la
création de l'annuaire locaux qui
étaient développées dans différentes
régions en ile de france on avait
récupéré
point.fr qui a existé à un moment qui
justement valoriser les entreprises de
la réparation est aujourd'hui on a créé
un annuaire sur le site annuaire les
réparations point fr vous pouvoir
trouver environ cent mille entreprises
delà de la réparation l'objectif
permettre aux consommateurs d'identifier
un artisan de la réparation
en un clic et de permettre de répondre
aux demandes des clients qui est de plus
en plus forte
aujourd'hui
pour rentrer dans cet annuaire il y a eu
de
contrainte on va dire deux exigences c1
c'est d'être un artisan d'être intégré à
la chambre des métiers d'artisanat et de
faire partie d'un code d'activité
il ya 36 code d'activité autour de
métiers tels que la réparation de
téléphones la réparation
d'électroménager de façon très classique
mais aussi ou promeut les entreprises de
goto shri de réparation bêtement de
bricolage milliers d'articles de maison
de meubles de coutellerie et bien sûr de
mobilier de jardin
et d'appareils de jardinage
l'objectif c'est vraiment pour voir
l'ensemble de ses artisans de la
réparation alors justement nature
un coutelier qui
la base de notre activité s'est créé
couteau diva et puis vous avez décidé
dernièrement de
diversifier un petit peu votre activité
et vous orienter vers
la compléter plutôt vers la réparation
l'affûtage de couteau et vous pouvez
nous expliquer un peu comment vous
fonctionnez autres comment comment vous
est venue cette idée d'abord et puis
comment vous la voulez traduisez de au
quotidien en essonne j'imagine parce que
c'est votre marché local et vous pouvez
nous dire un petit peu ce qui vous a
décidé l'ancêtre de cette
diversification est tout simplement les
clients qui
meurant comprend sur des salons
d'artisanat me demander si je pouvais
affûter leur cou de boeuf lors que de
cuisine alors au début je déballais en
imputant un deux trois trois couteaux de
tout client qui finalement la demande
s'est intensifiée j'ai quand on vous
donne un couteau on vous demande si vous
êtes capable d'acheter une paire de
ciseaux puis un sécateur ou autre chose
donc c'est là que j'ai une demande
intéressant ce qu'ils pouvaient répondre
seulement un besoin clair elle
qui en plus moi bien de permettre de
nourrir un chiffre d'affaires qui n'est
pas forcément toujours
heureux quand on pratique un métier
d'art
donc c'est une activi de l'affûtage
activité qui vient en complément de la
coutellerie les cas au moins autant
d'importance en termes de stratégie
d'entreprise pour le client c'est une
c'est une solution qui pour lui est
vraiment salvatrice parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui comptaient couteau
depuis des années qu'ils prennent la
route etc et je leur donne une seconde
vie et moi ça me permettre de continuer
à pratiquer mon métier de 38 ans
dépendantes passent plus les métiers
d'art sont une branche de leur vie alors
qu'il est très difficile de deux
sentiments oui et puis cette branche là
elle est très liés à l'événementiel
des déplacements sur des salons et des
foires aux vins alors du coup vous avez
vous promettez vous tranquille mais
votre marché les essonniens donc vous
avez une camionnette vous avez quelque
chose ou pas c'est dans les villages ou
alors c'est vraiment ça votre atelier
que vous aidez à ces activités
n'ont jusqu'à maintenant je travaille
est juste en cédant terrain mathieu des
gens venaient vre sur rendez vous
déposez dès lors ce type on parle que tu
vas général à ce que j'ai fait des
choses que maintenant et depuis peu j'ai
acquis un véhicule pour le transformer
en véhicule atelier donc les quasiment
fini
ici la fin du mois je pourrais
effectivement maintenant travailler à
une séance
pour deux types de clientèle
professionnelle pour les familles aux
pieds des restaurants et des boutiques
de coiffeur pour affûter leurs outils
instantanée ou les bouchers ou les
bouchers jean cloutier les ciseaux de
couturiers les biens s'il a déjà touché
dans l'accord de corps de métier et
aussi pour les particuliers où c'est
possible je suis en train d'organiser
avec sérieux kooning
moi je suis là sache voilà un petit peu
leur hôte ou trop vite parce que excusez
moi je fais un appartement mon papa
était bouché quand j'étais ferrite moi
je voyais le planning
n'est affûter les couteaux dans la
boucherie si on revient un petit peu aux
fondamentaux et je pense que
c'est ça oui à l'intention nous les
avons chassés oui à la pose de la
consommation après les spatialisation
les fondamentaux je pense que c'est plus
dur de nous parce que c'est nous qui les
avons chassés mardi
et je pense que tous les métiers
d'autrefois
vont redevenir en présence
je voudrais juste rajouter quelque chose
à cet endroit c'est que 1 nous penser la
chambre de métiers on est aussi là pour
accompagner les entreprises qui ont des
projets de diversification
c'est certes à dire que souvent ils sont
partis sur un
fonctionnement prévisionnel un chiffre
d'affaires prévisionnel et du coup de
rentrer dans un nouveau métier c'est pas
facile donc nous en tant que conseiller
chambre de métiers on est aussi là pour
les aider à calibrer 7 cette
diversification de leurs activités
j'imaginais un chiffre d'affaires
potentiel évalué des investissements à
faire il est accompagné jusqu'à
l'obtention éventuellement des de
financement des banques ce qui est
important d'avancer que ce niveau c'est
tout à fait possible et pas si compliqué
que ça adrien turin meetic particulier
c'est une niche la coutellerie c'est
quand même pas tous ses jetons coup tout
ça concerne pas tout le monde et donc du
coup vous avez bien pris le virage tout
en gardant d'activité de base bien pris
le virage la diversification pour vous
adapter aux besoins du marché ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose c'est tout à fait
possible et il faut pas hésiter et
les ajouts échos dma dans tous les
départements ils sont là pour ce job là
pour accompagner les artisans
d'information comme ça
et donc on va pouvoir avoir un petit
exemple de ce qu'est l'annuaire delà de
la réparation il est très simple
objectif ce que vous les 10 c en un clip
trouver un réparateur vous choisissez le
type de
n'a pas d'objet d'appareils que vous
voulez faire réparer avec votre code
postal ou votre ville et vous avez une
liste de réparateurs les plus proches
qui qui apparaissent comme vous pouvez
voir sur la diapositive sur la recherche
qui a été fait aujourd'hui il ya deux
entreprises qui sortent en premier ce
sont les fameux labellisé réparateur et
c'est un des avantages de cet annuaire
de rentrer dans la démarche vers leurs
acteurs d'apparaître en premier dans
dans l'annuaire de la réparation
mathieu
je pense que sam nécessite une
explication bien que là parce que moi
j'ai moi j'ai fait la macabre
quand vous m'avez parlé de réparateurs
il ya quelques temps j'ai fait la madame
est ce qu'on peut bien discerner
l'aspect de labellisation de
référencement tout à fait il ya deux
sur la diapositive qui précédentes vous
aviez deux choses qui sont bien
différentes c'est une page de
présentation de l'annuaire de la
réparation ou l'ensemble des artisans de
la réparation
sont présents peu importe ils sont
labellisés n'est pas labellisé c'est en
fonction de leur code d'activité c'est
votre votre code d'activité principal
fait partie des 36 code éligibles à
l'annuaire de réparation vous êtes
référencés dans l'annuaire de réparation
si ce n'est pas le cas ou s'il ya des
modifications à faire je vous invite à
contacter votre chambre de métiers et
d'artisanat pour mettre à jour votre
registre fiche c'est automatique c'est
automatique dans un second temps si vous
souhaitez vous rentrez dans la démarche
voulue engagé pour avoir de la
visibilité pour entrer dans un
réseau d'entreprise vous avez la
démarche et le label réparateur
globalement aujourd'hui pour avoir plus
de visibilité suffit de vous engager
dans le respect des valeurs du métier de
la réparation qui sont au quotidien
s'engager dans une démarche de
développement durable c'est à dire
respecter la réglementation sur la
gestion des déchets limiter son impact
environnemental
limitez vos consommations d'énergie
limitez votre consommation d'eau
sensibilisez vos clients à la réparation
ce que vous faites au quotidien
et pouvoir aussi avec nos sollicitations
de la chambre ou à des actions ou de
promotion de la réparation sur votre
territoire c'est
exactement ça fait partie des artisans
labellisés réparateur
accepté de participer à ce temps et on
les remercie encore et vous aussi vous
pouvez partir partie de ce réseau
d'acteurs épars acteur qui peut se
retrouver et qui sera promu culture sur
l'annuaire de la réparation sur la page
facebook nationale réparé acteur je
répare et salopards et on le verra par
la suite avec d'autres événements liés à
la communication
pour vous inscrire
il suffit de s'engager dans la charte
départ acteurs
cette charte et des ailes vous engage à
promouvoir l'action de réparation et
sensibiliser les artisans les clients
gratuit pris en charge à 100% charge pas
votre chambre de métiers d'artisanat
et comme vous agissez vous apparaissez
en premier dans les recherches de
l'annuaire de réparation à
position dans les recherches au milieu
de l'ensemble des acteurs de l'artisanat
ce que vous pouvez bénéficier en plus on
dire quand vous êtes artisan réparateur
labellisés par acteurs c'est d'avoir une
fiche détaillée de votre activité qui
est modifiable à votre demande avec vos
adresses numéros de téléphone site
internet bien sûr email si vous en avez
un et
la vente à jos qui a triplé par acteurs
c'est d'avoir ce descriptif et ses
horaires d'ouverture très intéressant et
important pour pour les clients de
savoir quand vous joins tisser ce
rendez-vous si c'est le samedi jusqu'à
quévert et de savoir exactement
le type d'activité au type de réparation
vous pouvez proposer
parce que ça peut arriver que l'activité
de de réparation informatique par
exemple on puisse être sollicités
régulièrement sur la réparation du
téléphone télévision jamais pas votre
coeur de métier donc voilà ça peut
permettre aussi à bien définir votre
action auprès des clients
donc comme on l'avait dit le label
réparé hector et 100% pris en charge par
votre chambre de métiers d'artisanat
avec le soutien de l'ademe
quand vous êtes labellisé réparateur
vous recevez un kit de communication en
version imprimée par la poste où je
donnais par votre conseiller chambre de
métiers il comprend un sticker à mettre
sur votre vitrine et une affiche ainsi
qu'un logo numérique que poèmes elle sur
votre site internet sur votre facture
sur vos dépliants
et qu'on pouvait être voir pour les
anciens labellisé actuellement le charte
graphique réparateur est en évolution
pour être modernisés avoir un écho
national
une campagne de communication en
traitement publique est menée également
on a eu il ya deux mois au mois de
juillet pour juillet une campagne sur
leboncoin
une grande visibilité sur le signe de la
mer de la réparation est sûre les
réparateurs et en novembre pendant la
serd la semaine européenne de réduction
des déchets une campagne de
communication sur les artisans de la
réparation et la visée est réparateur
est également prévue au niveau national
et parce que c'est ça l'enjeu en fait le
grand public connaisse la tanière le dr
white le consulter il voir dans un
périmètre proche question les artisans
réparateurs qui existe
c'est exactement ça sûr que notre robot
public vous mettiez votre équipier alors
là je propose qu'on regarde si vous la
connaissez pas la vidéo qui a été fait
pour le grand public un pur pour
promouvoir
l'annuaire gratteur
il ya l'annuaire le label un jeu
consiste bien là dessus
[Musique]
il faut qu'on pense qu'on la regarde al
dur de 3 minutes
[Musique]
votre appareil est en panne il si vous
alliez le faire réparer au lieu d'en
acheter un neuf réparer un bien c'est
prolonger sa durée de vie et ainsi faire
des économies
réduire les déchets et limiter
l'utilisation des ressources pour
préserver la planète consommer mieux
consommer autrement valoriser
l'artisanat local et participer à
l'économie de proximité créatrice
d'emplois et de lien social présent sur
tout le territoire
réparé acteurs vous propose de localiser
un professionnel de la réparation près
de chez vous sur
www.ratp.fr plus de cent mille
entreprises artisanales ils sont déjà
répertoriés près de 4500 artisans
labellisés
ces artisans réparateurs par leur
compétence leur savoir faire et leur
engagement met à l'honneur la réparation
de vos biens et équipements avant tout
remplacement par un objet neuf et il
répare tout
alors plus de temps à perdre courez chez
les réparateurs
réparé acteurs une initiative des
chambres de métiers et de l'artisanat
avec le soutien de l'ademe
alors donc on vient de voir la vidéo de
grand public ça m'amène à une question
parce que bon c'est vrai que le lan mais
red hat de 2019 est encore jeune
tout à fait exactement c'est encore
jeune il faut qu'ils prennent
il faut entendre pour que cet annuaire
iv énormément de visibilité et il faut
lui il faut aussi communiquer autour de
genève je voulais poser une question à
aller bas parce que est ce que vous vous
êtes vous labellisé il avait fait choix
de voulait mobiliser on l'a vu il ya
4500 labellisé en france sur son 1000
entreprises qui sont référencés qu elle
l avantage déstabiliser
l'ubs a dit quoi l'abattage réel
avantage riel c'est avoir une bonne
visibilité
les avoir aussi des retombées
de la réparabilité celle des personnes
vraiment viennent nous avons vu la
différence nous avons eu les c cela
s'étend même au delà même de notre
département ce que nous recevons du
q5
clients qui sont désespérés ne pas
priver de ré pas attaquer des clés zone
qui sont prêts à faire des kilomètres du
photocall jeter de trouver quelqu'un de
fiable et sérieux mais cemac le label
c'est quand même une reconnaissance
aussi d'engagement sérieux site est est
ce que vous pourriez évalué en plein
prix chiffre d'affaires chif
non pas que je sois métal mais j'ai
besoin de savoir
n'êtes vous pas lui la marque de
progression de notre chiffre d'affaires
à partir d'un nombre d'épis labellisés
est ce que vous pouvez essayer de
quantifier l'humain bon disons que c'est
peut-être pas une données consolidées
oui nous avons eu vraiment un banc de
plus de 5% adacore plus de 50%
j'ai dit par consolider parce que comme
nous sommes en pleine croissance
le monde être créés bon ça peut être
aussi interprété autrement plus tôt mois
partie du moment nous avons été
labellisé vrai nom est un bon et qui
continue de croître est ce que vous
faites le même constat france non je ne
pourrais pas dire moi personnellement si
la vie n'est pas si le fait d'être dans
l'annuaire ma porte pascal geslin je ne
demande pas d'où viennent les cris ça
fait chier pas nager flèche pas sir qui
viennent et j'ai dû tout venant et donc
je ne sais pas
ça vous démange et sharepoint client me
demande comment on nous avait connu
passé sur internet et ceux du gauche
alors justement on peut conseiller
adrien je sais pas si vous vous avez pu
mesurer la différence entre le moment où
vous avez été référencés et il avait
édité est-ce que vous pouvez plusieurs
aird faut dire que mon activité de
réparation et les jeunes les mon label
les jeunes eux aussi d'accord je
l'espère -
vous pourrez venir
c'est un chien qui a fait la démarche
d'être labellisé il vous appeler comme
il y avait été accompagnée par la
chambre nous appuyons disant voilà je
suis très intéressé pour être moi-même
labellisés comment est ce que je fais en
tout cas pour ceux qui ne le serait pas
ce qui est intéressant c'est peut-être
de pouvoir fléché comme le fait l'uba de
fléchissent qui hantait et peut-être de
leur demander au moins une seule
question est ce que vous venez de la
part de l'annuaire pour le réparateur et
ça ça peut être intéressant parce que
vous allez pouvoir mesurer
réelles retombées
ce que je voulais juste a ajouté que
grâce au label nous avons eu des
entreprises ils veulent par rapport à
leur est réservé ils sont venus nous
consulter monter un partenariat avec une
oui je confirme ce point le label comme
vous avez vu des évolutions
réglementaires forte et les
constructeurs et des grands
en magasin de vente grand public sont
très demandeurs d'artisans labellisés
pour pouvoir répondre justement aux
enjeux futurs
ça c'est quelque chose qui se
jettent tout à fait réelle
carole
donc je vous propose à présent de passer
à la partie plus pratique et comment
concrètement obtenir le label
concernant l'île de france mais c'est la
même chose dans toutes les chambres
régionales il faut se rendre sur le site
de l'acm mcdo france allait chercher
dans le menu déroulant l'appui aux
entreprises la rubrique développement
durable et au bout de la page vous allez
cliquer sur le lien qui va vous
permettre d'accéder au formulaire
d'inscription vous inquiétez pas l'oea
va mettre le lien dans le tchat donc ce
sera beaucoup plus rapide ja s'il
d'accès une fois que vous avez cliqué
sur ce lien
eh ben on va vous demander simplement de
renseigner votre numéro de siren pour
voir si effectivement votre activité
votre code principal d'activité et bien
éligible
à l'annuaire réparé acteurs et aux
labels
et puis après vous suivez simplement les
instructions les questions qui vous sont
posées la première question vous est
posée c'est est-ce que vous souhaitez
être labellisé réparateur dans ce cas là
vous cliquez dessus et puis vous allez
tomber sur une feuille qui va vous
expliquer quels sont les engagements
apprend donc les engagements apprend
c'est vraiment plus pour
signaler une démarche volontaire
d'engagement dans le développement
durable ce n'est pas extrêmement
contraignant en deux mots c'est
effectivement qu'on a déjà indiqué
mathieu c'est privilégier la réparation
plutôt que le remplacement par un bien
neuf s'est essayé dans la gestion
quotidienne de son entreprise de
diminuer son impact environnemental
évidemment en fonction des possibilités
de
et aussi de participer à un réseau ou à
des événements donc chez aussi chargé
développement territorial on travaille
beaucoup avec les collectivités on
essaye de plus en plus aussi d'organiser
des événements locaux pour sensibiliser
des habitants d'un territoire vous
autoriser la diffusion de vos
coordonnées et vous avez aussi une
petite ligne qui dit qu'en cas de
manquement vous avez le risque d'être
alliés mais je pense qu on n'arrivera
pas du tout là
pour finir
on va vous poser des questions sur votre
activité tels que vous souhaitez qu'elle
apparaît sur le site internet avant vous
a montré qu'il y avait un encart qui
était réservé aux entreprises
labellisées c'est le moment de vous
mettre en avant d'expliquer ce qui le ce
qui vous différencie de vos concurrents
et aussi quelles sont les spécificités
de votre démarche n'est pas deux mètres
haies 1 on peut vous joins un lycée sur
rendez vous quand est ce que vous êtes
vert etc
et puis une fois que vous avez cliqué
sur le petit bouton vous allez avoir un
message de confirmation comme quoi votre
demande a été bien prise en compte par
la chambre de métiers et qu'un
conseiller environnement vous confirmez
votre inscription par mail gros c'est
vrai aussi dans laquelle près de la
nature à peu près un kit de
communication au maximum avec le délai
d'envoi au maximum à moi c'est vraiment
le maximum
sous 15 jours voilà
maintenant
maintenant que vous avez franchi le pas
et que vous êtes dijoux lance dans la
démarche
réparateur je serai peut être labellisés
et bien sachez que vous avez la
possibilité d'aller plus loin en effet
dans le cadre du plan france coll ans le
gouvernement souhaite vraiment incité
très fortement les entreprises notamment
les tpe les pme à s'engager dans la
transition écologique et pour ce faire
l'état a mandaté notamment les jambes et
de métier pour aller à la rencontre des
entreprises et leur proposer de faire un
diagnostic très complet mais assez
rapide entre 45 minutes et une heure
trente sur les enjeux clés liées à la
transition écologique donc ces enjeux
clés sur lesquels
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
la réduction la revalorisation des
déchets est ce qu'il ya des économies
potentielles d'énergie à faire ou de
l'économie d'eau et aussi les démarches
de sensibilisation client fournisseur en
clair c'est un diagnostic va vous
permettre de briguer un petit peu tous
fonctionnement de votre entreprise et
surtout c'est là peut-être le plus
important de trouver des pistes pour
réduire vos coûts voire pour pouvoir
bénéficier des cas pas mal des danses
moments qui sont débloqués toujours dans
le cadre du plan france volant ce qui
s'appelle les aides tremplin et qui
concerne les entreprises notamment les
entreprises spécifiquement de la
réparation
pour les aider à développer leurs
activités c'est à dire former leurs
salariés
investir dans des outils numériques ou
dans des outils informatiques où on
monte le service à la clientèle
un autre projet est en cours c'est le
shaq verts de la région ile-de-france
qui lui aussi a pour objet d'inciter les
entreprises il a plié dans la rénovation
énergétique sur des postes très précis
ça pas besoin d'être une rénovation
extrêmement complète ça peut être juste
de changer l'éclairage renouveler sa
ventilation
retravaillé son isolation etc
voilà globalement un petit peu comment
pouvoir bénéficier concrètement des
avantages d'être accompagnés de la
chambre de métiers que ce soit de la
labellisation
jusqu'à la réalisation de ce diagnostic
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à nous
contacter ce soit mathieu pour
l'ile-de-france mois pour l'essonne pour
pouvoir bénéficier de cet accompagnement
sommes là pour répondre à toutes vos
questions
je rebondis sur ce que tu dis le à
carole parce que c'est en fait
durant cette semaine du développement
durable que l'essonne en tout cas pour
les soldes on lance cette opération de
diagnostic performa
c'est c'est quand même une prestation
qui peut être évaluée autour de entre
300 et 500 tout dépend si on prend la
phase d'accompagnement ou pas mais en
tout cas je vous incite vraiment à le
faire ça ne vous coûte rien tout est
pris en charge et ça va vous permettre
de faire des économies
d'avoir une démarche vertueuse en
désavantage c'est un rendez-vous en
face-à-face - conférence s'ils voulaient
me faisais avec vous pouvez vous voulez
essais à la clé derrière c'est un
bénéfice donc même vous qui est autour
de la table artisans mais cette loi je
dire il ya un diable numérique ont
inscrit des clubs numérique là on
s'inscrit aussi dans plan de relance on
offre du diag en vironnement ses mots
m'ont jamais y en aura pas pour tout le
monde je sais ce que j'ai l'impression
d'un nombre limité de données l'inciter
à
contacter votre chambre de métiers ouais
alors maintenant je pense qu'on peut si
vous êtes d'accord tous autour de la
table acea à ce moment d'échangé il nous
reste un petit quart d'heure si on
dépasse en dépasser programme ou alors
on est là pour vous
donc j'ai relevé quelques questions dans
le chat mais là je vous invite à aller
poser est alors j'ai vu que il était
dommage dans la vidéo qu'on que
l'activité de réparation mobilier
n'apparaissent pas alors je n'avais pas
constater c'est bien vous n'y aviez
mathieu
la réparation n'oubliez pas identifié
dans la vie des hobbies sont identifiés
dans l'annuaire je pense que c'est le
plus important
je n'ai pas précisément sur les 36 clubs
d'activités
les secteurs d'activité qui sont
éligibles à l'annuaire de réparation
réparateur
l'objectif c'est aussi de mobiliser les
entreprises les clients sur des secteurs
d'activité qui n'ont pas l'habitude
d'aller réparer
et c'est aussi pour ça que l'automobile
n'est pas présente dans l'annuaire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui toute personne sensée
c'est qu'il faut faire d'apparitions
nécessiteront pas aujourd'hui ça peut
être plus compliqué sur un couteau est
ce qu'il faut je peux le faire l'église
et combien ça me coûte je sais pas où
trouver un affûteur
associant
mon ordinateur c'est pareil et la
tondeuse je pense que
on aura des tas d'exemples comme ça
d'activité ou cherchent des acteurs de
la réparation les artisans qui vont à
savoir faire et l'annuaire et c'est pour
ça mais à j avais dire c'est pas une
super bonne remarque que les faits j'ai
pas à me relever le nom de la personne
qui nous posait cette question
marion mais pardon parce que honte à
tous du mobilier puis deux étages ils
m'ont
quand même à y a rien en mer ou même
voir et bien quand on est face à ce
débat soit c'est moi soit sam à la
poubelle ça c'est moi qui leur ai pas
attendre n'a pas les compétences et en
fait il ya beaucoup de cartes comme ça
et j'ai envie de dire ben moi je vais
peut-être entend communicante le dire
est peut-être le faire savoir parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'activités de de
réparation de meubles dans l'artisanat
et puis il va nous autres consommateurs
lambda on n'est pas toujours propre et
ans et avoir le temps de parer le meuble
libre à grand-mère accommode et donc
j'ai envie de dire c'est quand même il
ya un marché énorme là et donc je vais
peut-être je le remonte et on verra bien
ça mange pas d'accord du coup je peux me
permettre de rebondir j'ai vu aussi la
question danic un moment donné je crois
qui est couturière me semble-t-il et qui
elle réagit au fait qu'on ait annoncé
qu'il y avait un seuil psychologique de
30% de la valeur initiale du prix neuf
justement on a échangé avant et il n'y a
pas que cette notion là il ya aussi la
notion de relation affective à l'objet
et c'est adrien qui nous disait que sur
certains objets et gens étaient prêts à
payer la réparation deux ou trois fois
la la valeur initiale du de l'objet
parce que cet objet a une valeur
sentimentale pour eux et c'est vrai car
marc de la grand mère même si elle est
bancal et tout a dit non je peux pas
l'acheter c'est pas possible eh bien
peut-être effectivement cette somme que
je dépense pour acheter du neuf mais
finalement je préfère garder l'armoire
de mon art est à l'honneur et c'est ça
qui est très important donc ce seuil de
30% ce je dirais ce sont peut-être sur
des produits basiques mais à partir du
moment où il ya un lien actif avec le à
réparer les gens pendant on pas
forcément cette limite ya en tête les 3%
c'est une valeur d'études on va dire ça
et globale mais aussi la démarche du
consommateur qui vient je viens faire
réparer il est peut-être celui-ci fait
la démarche d'aller dans l'annuaire et
chercher un réparateur et peut être plus
et puis il ya la notion d'urgence que
dans mon jeu pour moi ce que je connais
mais quand j'ai un cuisinier qui jaguar
et qui là qu'il a abîmé la pointe de son
couteau mais qu'il en absence que c'est
son couteau fétiche pour travailler ils
sont fous de m vioreau ou de soir ou de
ce qu'il veut c'est un petit travail qui
fonctionne elle qui marche je pense que
dans tous les corps de métiers de la
réparation c'est lui c'est ça cet outil
la parano toute la suisse y
penser au fond moi je connais je fais
partie d'un réseau d'acteurs nationale
mais je constate des choses sur les prix
il ya beaucoup d' affûteur je pense que
c'est pas trop creuser twitter je pense
que cet artisan qui calculent leurs prix
de prestations au doigt mouillé sauf que
justement je pars du principe que vous
pas dépasser 20% 30% parce que c'est
comme ça l'explication d'un peu plus
loin il ya beaucoup de gens qui font
faillite et qui cassent les prix des
marchés en plus c'est donc le 30 % pour
moi c'est vraiment un titre indicatif ça
dépend de l'outil de sa valeur
effectivement la valeur sentimentale et
aussi de l'importance de beauty c'est
que moi je le fus et des outils pour des
maroquiniers ils sont tous à la
recherche de sous type il ya quarante
ans que l'ati été meilleur ils sont
prêts à mettre le prix pour l'accepter
parce qu'ils savent que derrière ils ont
ils ont un outil qui va qui verrouillent
une valeur indicative mais on a
l'habitude ce qui nous intéresse pas de
que les entreprises aussi de la
réparation s'asseoir chiffre un et il
est agréé sous la porte donc c'est il
faut le coût de la réparation a évalué
en fonction de la matière qu'on va
utiliser jeu remplacement du temps passé
des charges fonctionnel et autres donc
bon à 30% c'est ça mais je
il y avait une question d'une couturière
qui tournait autour de ça donc pas de
panique voilà qui est indicatif alors
j'ai vu imploserait question que alors
une femme est labellisé qu'il mobilisés
mais n'a pas allait labelliser le
braqueur mais n'a pas reçu voilà c'est
annick pas donc pas moi ni vous n'avez
pas n'avait reçu que de stickers et non
la fiche ni la manière
est bannie que
mon sens ok
si vous êtes inscrits jeu vos
coordonnées je vous rappelle cet
après-midi pour lisa voilà un concurrent
qui me les a piqués
ça s'est fait
entre contacts dans la soul eater
webinaire
ok qu'est ce que j'y vais comme si les
couleurs et passion
si le coudray paraissent réparation
réduit à 30 % cela ne réduit pas les
revenus des réparateurs site est il des
primes pour les réparateurs ou là alors
je pense que ça à la fois sur les 30% la
fin de barrières psychologiques dont
convient d'évoquer ya peut-être aussi le
lundi sont la réparation donc c'est pas
une réduction c'est juste que vous serez
payé peut-être 30% à 70% du prix aux
clients et 30% qui seront facturés à
l'éco organisme sera identifié à partir
du 1er janvier donc il n'ya pas de perte
du tout pour l'année en cours
jusqu'à peut-être 30 % et + en charge
par le fait alors une autre question
danic je suis retoucheuse en couture
labellisés et inscrits dans l'annuaire
des réparateurs mais je n'ai pas eu de
nouveaux clients suite à cela avez vous
communiquer sur ce sujet madame
parce que en fait moi je prends ma
casquette comme
là pour le coup vous êtes labellisés il
faut le faire savoir pour le faire
savoir sur tous les médias dont vous
disposez alors les réseaux sociaux votre
psy de votre courrier tout votre
matériel administratif
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'autres faisant ce
que moi je les missions d'un fils
balayage de la belle ainsi alors moi je
vais afficher aussi dans la boutique jeu
là et chaque fois que que je discute
avec mes clients je leur montre en fait
le label oui je leur dis voilà en août
notre démarche c'est réparé acteurs et
donc je leur montre que gardez vous
trouverez aussi dessus d'autres artisans
qui répare et donc quand on demande donc
de réparer des télés que je ne sais pas
je les dirige vers l'annuaire très bien
donc et c'est aussi à nous je pense que
chacun commence de mettre en avant ce
label directement et surtout les média
support du projet votre voiture
je sais pas vous mais les fans vous
pourrez faire un petit sticker
maison sur nos factures cie s'est pas tu
as tout le matériel sur notre facture
sous la fin de cette visite
si vous n'avez pas les outils
de communication par m vous recevez le
logo version numérique pour l'utiliser
mais si vous les avez pas n'hésitez pas
à nous contacter
vous accompagnez
vous aider à un communiqué
encore une fois c'est vrai que la
culture c'est pas un métier utile
l'apparation tel qu'on l'entend celle
que c'est pour ça que là que le projet
aussi de communiquer au grand public sur
l'ensemble de ses métiers c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont été choisis c'est un travail
de
longue haleine on peut dire faire en
conscience aux consommateurs que il ya
d'autres métiers de la réparation qui
sont qui sont connus alors une autre
oui j'ai publié sur les réseaux sociaux
sur la bouture aussi pour continuer la
nique vous allez là comme ces
seizièmes du nuage voilà comme c'est à
répétition c'est ça c'est cette novation
c'est et jusqu'à bojan n'y avait pas de
communication nationale justement auprès
du consommateur justement alors je vous
rassure en essonne là on rentre dans une
démarche de communication sur l'annuaire
de france aussi au niveau national hans
qui vont reprendre les plans média de
communication
c'est un sujet qui est assez nouveau
c'est ça
on est dans un changement de mentalité
je pense que vous y êtes c'est essentiel
je vous invite vous est labellisé 8 donc
voilà fait de la com au maximum par les
autres vous associez vous aussi à
d'autres opérateurs dribbles de la
réparation de votre zone de chalandise
même s'ils n'ont pas la même activité à
il faut mais top tout autant de temps
additionnel tous les restaurants voilà
même dans une bise à une association de
commerçants d'artisans il faut il fait
comment signaler enfin c'est vraiment
tout ça qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre les
réseaux en fait mais les réseaux le vrai
réseau le fret le document c'est ça que
les réseaux sociaux vos clients et
clients c'est simple si
alors vous allez rire les questions sur
le site internet
alors oui en effet valve éveillé alors
que vous savez l'informatique ça vite le
site
n'a que deux ans et en luttant à a déjà
deux ans et donc il va être belle et
évolutive dans les mois qui viennent
justement pour faciliter sa l'objectif
c'est de permettre aux consommateurs
aussi d'aller très rapidement c'est pour
ça qu'on a une liste déroulante avec des
choix et la séduction d'une ville c'est
vrai que si vous faites que la ville
vous aurez tous les réparateurs qui sont
présents il faudra identifier un par un
les activités et pour les compétences
métiers
de précis de l'artisan c'est là un des
avantages puisque labellisé réparateur
alors une question danic merci pour
toutes ces questions annick il me semble
que pour bénéficier des aides
transnumériques il faut au minimum une
dizaine rothschild 900000 euros 1
500 semble imminent
mais en dessous de cette somme on n'a
droit à rien alors mathieu alors france
le numérique c'est alors veut dire
contacter votre conseiller numérique à
champ de vision parce que je n'ai pas
d'informations à vous dînez sur france
numérique sur les parties environnement
il ya des aides qui existent
carroll a présenté les lettres en
plaques sont justement dédié pour les
entreprises pour les tpe des axes une
action très simple une aide très simple
pour la partie environnement
je vous invite à contacter votre
conseiller pour qu'on puisse voir avec
vous qui êtes vous avez besoin
mais pas me donner plus d'informations
après pour le numérique on peut essayer
de trouver un meilleur agencement des
jeunes au sein de notre réseau est ce
qu'on peut être amené à annick à vous
répondre en interrogeant un référent des
numériques qui travaillerait au
développement économique de la cmu ou
une autre celle de son jeu je vous
rappeler
sur
trois y évoquait ce volet là lien
alors je crois comme je crois pas avoir
d'autres questions
non je ne crois pas je je voudrais
donner la parole à mme ali ben du bain
qu'est-ce que quels conseils
donneriez-vous à nos partisans
là qu'ils soient en face de nous qui
sont pour la plupart des artisans sont
essentiellement des articles dans la
réparation par rapport à la légalisation
par rapport à
cette démarche-là
durable
je dois partir de ce que nous avons vu
la première chose de le battre c'est
d'être avec les autres acteurs de même
s'ils n'évoluent pas dans le même
secteur
la seconde chose c'est vraiment elle
soit et nous dès qu'on avait eues mais
la belle tout de suite de la mission
notre page facebook ou de l'avant
explique google dans la vie et il y a
des gens qui nous ont rendez-vous ce
qu'ils ont
nous l'avons affiché partout si vous
venez dans mon
cher paul daley dans les forums puisque
justement oui
c'est ça aussi un pour nous les artisans
pour qu'on reste est rentré dans mon
atelier on ne nous allons nous écumons
mais les programmes de centres du
département et des communes
sur les forums qui existe et nous allons
sur place et avec notre label genre
affichée et nous avons les stands
expliquant aux gens ce que la réparation
pour pour paul et les
hoquets du jardin c'est jamais sans mon
label
on est ça mais c'est vrai que là
maintenant je viens d'arriver
et d'essonne mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
une vraie demande aussi de la part des
communes est aussi l'opération sur ces
thématiques là sont très enclin à
effectivement mettre en contact et
salons des réparations faire venir des
recycleries mais aussi des artisans donc
je pense que l'année à venir sera
vraiment propice à l'organisation de si
on pourra
organiser ce genre d'événement est à
vendre ces entreprises visible aussi
très localement du coup pas cessé avec
leur commune ou leur agglomération ça
sera forcément des clients autour de
chez eux qu'ils seront qui sera
sensibilisé et il ya une chose sur
laquelle je rebondirai ces réparateurs
ou soient labellisés ou pas j'ai envie
de dire si une communauté et cette
question de la communauté elle est à
travailler j'ai envie de dire aux
entreprises de réparation échangés entre
vous alors peut-être qu'un jour nous on
créera un club mais normal et donc elle
est dans les tuyaux c'est dans les
tuyaux a donc dû me
va c'est commune était là entretenez la
regrouper vous échanger sur vos
pratiques
je loge l'instit complètement puisque
nous à morsang-sur-orge on a une
association des professionnels de
morsent qui a été créée donc en 2013
maintenant ils n'avaient pas contre elle
ne l'est plus et c'est vrai qu'en se
regroupant en tant que professionnels de
tous finalement de tout de tout
transfert de toutes les activités que ça
va de la santé ou
à la vente en primeur garagiste voilà
etc artisan plomberie avec finalement se
retrouver de temps en temps d'avoir un
mouton on a aussi notre annuaire pour
distribuer dans la vie ça nous permet de
nous connaître de dire ah bah oui alors
j'ai quelqu'un qui est bâtir gym
ostéopathe alors oui je connais elle est
très bien ag un réparateur informatique
oui ben ali a fait c'est très bien et en
fait on se cooptent les uns et les
autres et on se découvre on fait du
comment dire dormez commence avec la
recommandation est en fait on a quand on
se connaît en fait ces petits coups
faciles c'est beaucoup plus facile et là
il ya un moyen de man ray attractivité
qui est commune alain simon c'est le
lien s'est amusé à tout à l'heure vous
disiez très bien où adrien où vous êtes
affilié à
l'entreprise davantage les associations
d'autres les affûtage donc là vous avez
choisi votre activité directe mais ça
peut se faire aussi en est simple vous
pouvez prendre des contacts on avait un
petit mail sur une acti été tiens je
cherche un truc
c'est un outil
de liens entrants 30 entre les
entreprises des activités atteint un
point d'eau on en est au début c'était
très compliqué de faire changer les
mentalités de cette démarrer des
nouveaux sujets mais j'ai envie de dire
que ça va bien là un coup d'accélérateur
à ce
jeu les défis si le dernier mot de la
fin vous ayez des choses à dire de
julien florence
est en tout cas ce que ce que j'ai à
dire c'est un grand merci à vous artisan
qui prenaient de votre temps votre
précieux temps pour nous pour nous
consacrer et surtout le consacrer à
avaux pas aux mollahs un grand merci
sachez que si vous connaissez des gens
des réparations date voilà ce replay
sera unique et sur notre site de la
conférence est enregistrée elle sera
communiquée et à grand merci à vous
vraiment c'est important d'entendre ce
que vous ressentez comment vous mettez
en place les choses et puis ben je
laisse le mot de la fin pour lui pour
mathieu c'était pas prévu mais voilà
j'ai décidé
je
vais une chose très importante
si vous êtes labellisés et l'appariteur
il vous avez la moindre question la mode
de monde contactez moi au constructeur
votre conseiller et si vous êtes vous
souhaitez vous la bi lisez vous avez des
questions contactez votre conseiller ou
si on est là pour vous pour vous
accompagner dans cette démarche est de
réussir à à créer un réseau c'est vrai
que les évolutions avoir sont fortes sur
le dossier de la réparation il va avoir
des enjeux financiers due forme la
réparation des choses comme ça et si
vous êtes labellisés par hector on va
pouvoir vous communiquez directement les
éléments de
sur cette thématique donc vraiment
n'hésitez pas
engagez-vous dans le monde appelle
réapparaître merci à tous et bonne
journée
c'est pourquoi